εγώ θεωρώ ότι υπάρχει αυτό θεωρώ ότι υπάρχει αρκετή βοήθεια και πολύ καλύτεροι τώρα πάρά
πό πιο παλιτελο πάντο όμως κατιδική που γνώμη επιίδίτελευτά πέτε χρόνια πλών ζω στην κύπρον
και βλέπου τα πράγματα πιο παθιάκόμα είναι σαν να δίνο ένα δώρο σι σε κάποιον
το οποίο δεν το δεν μπορά το αξιοποιής ιατί τί να το κάμω από τις
θισμή που δεν υπάρχουν χώρι προπόνησης σωστη δεν υπάρχουν υποδομές στάδια μας είναιυποδιάληση κάποια να
δίνω κίνητρα ναδίνο κάποια χρηματικά πο σα σε κάποιους αθελτές και να μην έχουν το
χώρο να γιναστούν καταλαβαίνεισ ότι κάπως πετάσε στα χρήματα δεν υπάρχουν προπονητές και ο λόγος
είναι ότι σα αυτό το κομμάτι είναι τον ενιντα πέντε εκατόν που τελιώο γνασιμια κατιμία
κάνεις το εούτε να πέτε τις εκατό δεν επιλέγει των κλασσικών αθιλητισμό γιατί κακαταψέματα το
ποδόφρο εναι πολλά τα χρήματα σουτα πιστό ανέτσι αν κάνω θα έχω πολύ ποερισσότερα ισοδήματα
όποτε πολι γυμναστές προπονητές όπως έλις πέτο δεν επιλέγουν το χώρο μας για τους εξεις
λόγους και νομίζζω ότι αυτό είναι εξωτερικό ιαδ είναι να πρόλημα το οποίο οι όμως
πονδία τους στοίβου εδώ και που λλά χρόνια δεν ξιοποίησετουλάχιστον και τις δικές μας επιτυχίες
τη δική μου επιτυχία του μίλαν του παρέλλι κάποιον παιδιών που έχουμε δείξει έχουμε πάει
σε άλλον επιπέδον των στοίβο από τα παλιά χρόνια δεν αξιοποίησαν τις δικές μας επιτυχίες
στο να κάνουμε κάτι για το μέλο το έ στον είναι προσωπική μου γνώνη μπορεί
να υπάρχουν χρήματα πυ να υπάρχουν κινητερας στους αφελτές άλλα ξα ναλέω με τι μέσαμε